[Musica]
rimasto lo vede
assolta nel frattempo
attenzione leggere e conservare le parti
piccole potrebbero essere ingerite o
inalate
nuoce gravemente alla salute provare a
realizzare i vostri sogni
asfa nen non si fa
iamm heroes chef abitava al cairo e come
ogni notte faceva sempre lo stesso sogno
e sognava un uomo tutto bagnato che si
toglieva una moneta di bocca gli dice
vai amir la tua fortuna è a terra tu
devi prendere e andare a teheran e così
dopo una settimana dopo un mese dopo un
anno che hai amir faceva sempre lo
stesso sogno ho preso il suo fagottino e
parti e arrivo a terra proprio
sull'imbrunire quando nella piazza allo
stesso tempo arrivavano i briganti e
briganti rubarono saccheggiarono tutto
lasciarono tre o quattro morti in giro
quando arrivò la polizia trovò solo
lamiere lì come un fesso lo restarono lo
presero a legnate per tre giorni e poi
ha rivolto mandante per interrogarlo e
io mi disse comandante è colpa del sogno
il comandante guardandolo scandendo lo
disse ma tu non devi credere i sogni
sogni sono delle gran cavolate pensa che
io a da una vita che sono un giardino
con dentro una meridiana e dentro un
cespuglio e dopo cespuglio un pozzo e
dentro il pozzo un immenso tesoro pensa
se fosse partito a cercarlo a quest'ora
sarei ricchissimo ma una gran cavolata
non ci devi credere ora ti faccio di
temperare te ne torni a casa e così gli
amir dopo qualche tempo ritorna a casa
ed entra nel giardino vede la meridiana
passa cespuglio vede il pozzo e trova
l'immenso tesoro
questa storia perché se credessimo a
tutto ciò che ci viene detto alle
negazioni imposte alla poca fiducia
talvolta riposta nell'innovazione non
andremo certamente lontano
fortunatamente esiste chi crede nel
futuro è prima di tutto ancora in se
stesso come jamir nascono così viaggi
rocamboleschi alla ricerca di una
soluzione ad una domanda che ancora non
esisteva tra immaginazione e realtà in
quel limbo sottile ma così intrigante ed
attanagliare lamenta progetti
avveniristici
vi siete mai trovati nella complicata
condizione di dover realizzare il vostro
sogno vi siete mai trovati in quel limbo
destabilizzante di non comprendere più
se siano più forti
le vostre origini o il vostro futuro e
di sentirvi dire non si può fare
ecco io sì e questo mi ha sempre dato la
forza per combattere e vincere su quei
no quelli inutili e
se fossi partito cercarlo diceva il
comandante ha già mila il se è la
congiunzione degli indecisi dei perdenti
nella vita si diventa grande nonostante
che nonostante le peggiori ingiustizie
subite nonostante le disgrazie
nonostante le mancanze
nonostante dias fan e
ricordo che quando ero bambino era un
bambino timido ed introverso al tempo
stesso mi piaceva sognare disegnare e
creare cambiare le cose
un giorno prendo in mano un album è una
matita inizio replicare sulla carta
quelle forme riconducibili a delle
automobili
tutt'a un tratto quella matita diventa
la chiave della mia stanza segreta alla
stanza della creatività dove potevo
rifugiarmi c in qualsiasi momento lo
volessi ed alla stanza
la terra di nessuno quella che tutti
abbiamo perché la creatività e lusso che
tutti ci possiamo concedere in ogni
ambito ed è gratis
al contempo a scuola i quaderni
diventano delle quelli di matematica
delle officine sui suoi quadretti e
quelli di italiano non sulle righe
faccio corre delle ruote della mia
fantasia fuori da quella banco fuori da
quella scuola fuori da quella città
tuttavia la strada
qualcosa qualcuno a volte mi chiamava la
maestra alla lavagna e quella era la
maestra scusate e la maestra non aveva
le chiavi della della mia stanza
della creatività ma
quando se ne accorse che io non c'ero in
aula prese le chiavi e le butto via
e quelli erano anche gli anni delle
delusioni perché i miei quaderni a casa
vestiti di rosso
negli anni invece decisioni quando
dovevo decidere che cosa fare del mio
futuro a 18 anni
decido di riandare a cercare quelle
chiavi dove che aprivano la stanza dove
c'era veramente la mia forza è che
decido di andare a torino prende un
treno e decido di andare ad imparare a
disegnare l'automobile è quella che è
passione diventa studio per diventare
poi professione
tuttavia la strada per emergere era
abbastanza ardua perché ai colloqui
rubano i disegni mentre nei centri stile
o mettono la firma di noi creativi ma
nel 2013 esce anche una notizia che dice
che un giovane bellunese ha disegnato un
automobile l'automobile più vendute in
cina un auto molto popolare un'auto che
sorride che assomiglia al pesciolino
nemo ed effettivamente l'avevo disegnata
come il pesciolino nemo con una bocca
e con che sorrideva e con degli occhi al
posto dei fanali
il
la notizia piace piace moltissimo ma non
piace alla mia azienda che dicendo lei
disegnata su quella macchina e allora
nasce anche un processo dal quale dovevo
difendermi ma in maniera era molto
difficile perché i disegni non parlano
allora fece capire però i giudici che
quello stesso linguaggio stilistico era
stato ripreso lungo tutti i progetti che
avevo fatto nel corso del tempo perché
quella stanza della cattività era
diventata una fucina da dove attingere
intuizioni idee
avevo disegnato le sorpresine kinder
avevo disegnato gli occhiali aver
disegnato arredamento avevo disegnato
architetture e così vincono la battaglia
della verità da quel momento decido di
disegnare soltanto auto che portano il
mio nome e che sono vanto della mobilità
eco sostenibile la mobilità pulita
mi trovo a ginjou in henan e
dall'alto di una cima di un hotel
riscopro con suo paese un disegno che
non era invecchiato era rimasto giovane
come una sorta di dorian gray
dell'automobile decidono di realizzarlo
metterlo su strada
torno in italia insieme alla complicità
la bravura del mio socio paolo
decidiamo di andare a salone
dell'automobile di torino il nome
frangivento perché tutto ciò che si
muove frange il vento
il tempo era poco soltanto due mesi e
noi eravamo pochi soltanto in due
persone allora andiamo a cercare un
aiuto nelle aziende torinesi per
realizzare questa automobile
spesso ci si trovava all'uscio con una
pacca sulla spalla e una spa né
allora torno in officina da salvatore
papà di paolo e chiedo ma salvatore cosa
significa fun and e saluta ma sai
giorgio dias fan n sentirai a bizzeffe
in piemonte non ce la faremo mai ad
arrivare al sogno dell'automobile di
torino mancano soltanto due mesi non
abbiamo le risorse la determinazione
aumentava il giorno dopo giorno e sogno
di portare l'automobile il concept
dell'automobile elettrica
la prima in italia al salone di torino
era è molto ambizioso
il 6 giugno infatti del 2016 esordisce e
si svela al pubblico quell'auto che
portava il nome di as far as fan è la
contrazione di quel detto demoralizzante
era diventato per noi il nostro cavallo
di battaglia per sconfiggere tutte le
opposizioni che trovavamo fra noi e il
nostro sogno
e adesso mentre raccolgo i pezzettini di
questa automobile
voglio farvi un regalo perché credo che
ognuno di voi in questa platea abbia un
cassetto socchiuso e da riaprire con un
sogno da rispolverare
perché credo che con
creatività
l'ambizione costanza si possa fare as
fanelli
[Applauso]
[Musica]